[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight one of the reasons that most of
the Western world embraced unprecedented
mass quarantines this spring was due to
the work of a single man a man who may
have not have heard of he's a British
academic called Neil Ferguson Ferguson
is a professor at a college in London
but he's also something of an
international celebrity he is best known
for his dire predictions about pandemics
Ferguson seemed especially panicked by
the Wuhan coronavirus at one point he
suggested the krona virus might be
comparable to the Spanish flu of 1918
the pandemic that killed up to a hundred
million people on February 28th of this
year as the disease spread throughout
Europe
Ferguson publicly endorsed the Chinese
model of quarantine specifically now
keep in mind that as Ferguson spoke the
words you're about to see videos were
circulated on the internet showing
police in Wuhan throwing screaming
citizens into the back of panel trucks
and driving them to some unspecified
internment somewhere Ferguson must have
known that the Chinese government's
response in Wuhan was extreme and
utterly inhumane he endorsed it anyway
that's how serious Neil Ferguson was
about this virus one has to adopt the
sort of community measures which have
been adopted particularly in places like
Wuhan and China where you try to reduce
contacts between people in the community
so the sorts of measures which are
important are first of all if anybody
has any sort of respiratory disease and
cold anything to stay at home until
those symptoms are fully resolved seems
like kind of a reserved academic and all
of a sudden he's endorsing the Wuhan
response
leaders around the world paid attention
to this
they took Ferguson's advice and locked
down their entire populations the
British government asked Ferguson to
help design its quarantines as a member
of the scientific advisory group for
emergency sage Ferguson was happy to
help shut down the entire United Kingdom
but it turns out he wasn't that
interested at all in participating in it
personally today The Telegraph newspaper
reported that Niall Ferguson ignored his
own lockdowns well the rest of London
stayed trapped indoors indeed the rest
of the country Ferguson repeatedly
invited
married mistress over to his apartment
for sex and then perhaps most striking
of all he was infected with the corona
virus at the time Neil Ferguson became
sick and tested positive in mid-march we
know this because he said so publicly at
the time not long after that he invited
his mistress over by doing this he
exposed her to a deadly virus he also
exposed her husband and her children
back home when confronted today Ferguson
said this quote I acted in the belief
that I was immune that was his
explanation the problem is there is no
scientific proof that that's true can
someone who was sick a few weeks ago
still transmit the corona virus we're
not sure for a famous scientist Neil
Ferguson is curiously ignorant of
science
he's also obviously an appalling
hypocrite and he's not alone in that so
many of the people making our policies
are like this almost compulsively again
and again they do the very things they
punish us for doing when they're caught
they acknowledge no shame they are
entirely lacking in self-awareness they
have no idea how absurd they are they
discredit themselves without even
realizing it almost immediately after
telling the rest of New York City to
stay inside for example Mayor Bill
DeBlasio loaded up his SUV with
government bodyguards and headed for the
gym across town in Brooklyn a government
spokesman later explained the trip was
necessary
because de Blasio is Jim quote has been
a huge part of his and his family's life
okay that makes sense
de Blasio who likes his gym so Hipp
going there despite telling you not to
got it
weeks later de Blasio still couldn't
stay out of Brooklyn for some reason one
day he and his wife left their home in
Manhattan Gracie Mansion and drove more
than ten miles to Prospect Park in
Brooklyn for some sunshine and some
fresh air a stunned citizen happened to
see the whole thing and videotaped it
here's what happened seriously you guys
have a park you live in the middle of a
park you don't need to not essentially
travel to Brooklyn
come on you won't even open roads for
people of all backgrounds I'm not gonna
give it a break this is selfish behavior
this is the epitome of non-essential
travel non-essential travel what's that
when you make the rules that's not even
a category just has Justin Trudeau the
preachy Prime Minister of Canada on
April 12 Trudeau released a video
commanding Canadians to stay in their
homes for Easter it's what Jesus would
do he declared so as we reflect on
Jesus's message of love and compassion
let's think about our health care
workers and essential service workers
who are on the front lines every day
that's put into practice what it truly
means to love our neighbors as ourselves
by making sacrifices to protect their
health let's stay home for them that's
the kind of quarantine Jesus endorses
love means staying home for you not for
them not long after recording the video
you just saw Trudeau left the capital
and traveled all the way to Quebec to
visit his family at their lake house
just like you'd want to do on Easter if
you were allowed to do that but you're
not allowed so stop complaining you
might also want to get your hair cut
people do and in Chicago last month that
was not allowed you couldn't get your
hair cut but the city's mayor Lori
Lightfoot had her hair done anyway when
she was caught doing this Lightfoot
didn't even blush now he played this
clip for you on Friday show but it's one
of those videos that no matter how many
times you watch it drops your jaw every
time I'm the public face of this city
I'm on national media and I'm out in the
public eye and you know I'm a I'm a
person who I take my personal hygiene
very seriously as I said I felt like I
needed to have a haircut I'm not able to
do that myself and so I got a haircut
got that shut up proles
I'm on national television Chris Cuomo
knows that feeling very well
last month the scene an anchor drove to
a piece of property he owns in the
Hamptons where apparently he's building
a new weekend house at the time
was infected with the corona virus and
suffering from symptoms he was supposed
to be quarantined in total isolation in
his basement full-time that's we told
his television audience he was night
after night coma put on shows that
revolved around his struggles with the
illness in his virtuous even selfless
efforts to prevent others from getting
infected with it given all the publicity
he was generating for being sick at
least one Hamptons resident was shocked
to see him out and about and confronted
cuomo about it
Cuomo responded by calling the man a
quote jackass a loser man's real name is
David Whelan and we invited him on the
show to hear his story I just said don't
you have the coronavirus shouldn't you
be quarantined and my biggest next words
were what the hell do you know about
this what do you know about the rules I
said you're not supposed to be out here
nobody had gloves on nobody had masks on
oh did you hear that detail no gloves no
mask an infected man circulating among
an unsuspecting population when you
watch television you imagine Chris Cuomo
is a responsible journalist that's how
he often describes himself in fact he's
typhoid mary and there's a vast gap
between those two personas for the
average person hypocrisy is the most
embarrassing thing of all getting caught
the way Chris Cuomo did would spur an
existential crisis in most people you
might decide to devote the rest of your
life to personal humility in response
you might move to Paraguay and shame and
never speak in public again but not
Chris Cuomo he didn't look back he
blamed the other guy and kept going
Cuomo was right there on television just
last night her ranking people for doing
precisely what he did but there's also
feel fatigue I've had it seasons
changing it's getting warm want to get
back to it look at these fools fools I
know they want to be out there
fools it's not about you what about the
other people and look I'm not gonna
castigate you that's not my job I'm not
your daddy
fools it's not about you says the buff
CNN anchor because if there's one thing
in this world that Chris Cuomo just
can't stand it's narcissism he hates it
it doesn't seem to occur to Chris Cuomo
for a moment that he may be actually
describing himself it never occurs to
any of these people it's never one time
occurred to Chris Como's brother the
governor of New York Andrew Cuomo just
gave a pungent press briefing as he so
often does maybe you saw it if not watch
this clip and tell us what you notice I
think it's disrespectful of people not
to wear masks I mean think about it
do I think local government should be
enforcing it and should there be
sanctions yes yes because it is a public
health emergency then I think there
should be a penalty because you could a
little literally kill someone you could
literally kill someone because you
didn't want to wear a mask here that
Dumbo you're hard-of-hearing listen up
it's disrespectful you could literally
kill someone by not wearing a mask says
the man not wearing a mask who happens
to be sitting next to other people who
are not wearing masks do they hear
themselves when they talk like this on
some level they do they know they're
hypocritical frauds and that's exactly
why they lecture you so hysterically it
makes them feel better
they probably suspect you know it too
it's just so obvious they simply don't
care enough about your opinion to bother
with what you think that's all of them
this would be infuriating if these
people didn't run the world but it's
worse than that because they do